c'est pas une bonne semaine pour les
libéraux parce que en france il ya donc
cette réforme vous nous avez expliqué
ferghana ziari que l'était tout sauf
libéral et au royaume uni vous savez il
ya des élections demain des élections
législatives le thème qui écrase tout
c'est bien sûr le break site
mais il n'ya pas que ça et quand on
regarde les programmes des deux grands
partis en lice c'est vraiment à gauche
toute
alors chez les travaillistes c'est
peut-être moins surprenant
leur leader jeremy corbyn veut augmenter
de 80 milliards de livres la dépense
publique
il veut revenir sur toutes les mesures
de margaret thatcher notamment en
rationalisant le train l'électricité et
les télécoms mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que du côté des conservateurs donc
de boris johnson
aussi on semble rompre avec le
libéralisme
d'abord avec le peut-être le break site
qui est un moyen de sortir d'une zone de
libre échange
à moins que ce soit le contraire puisque
c'est pour retrouver une certaine
liberté je vois faire ghana diaries qui
hochent la tête qui est peut-être sur
cette ligne là mais il ya aussi une
augmentation des dépenses publiques plus
26 milliards de livres propose le
candidat conservateur
ça c'est uniquement pour le système
national de santé pharmacie arrive votre
point de vue margaret thatcher est morte
une deuxième fois je fais pas ci
alimente une seconde fois ce qui est sûr
effectivement c'est que là c'est la fin
d'un consensus c'est à dire que margaret
thatcher
après effectivement avoir dirigé le
royaume uni avait une phrase célèbre
quand on lui a demandé quel est votre
plus grande victoire
elle lui répondait à l'époque ma plus
grande victoire c'est celle c'est le
leader qui en fait c'est aussi converti
à l'économie de marché
puisqu'à l'époque elle avait bâti un
consensus autour du fait qu
effectivement ces réformes avait réussi
à redresser l'angleterre puisque on
avait le le jeu fmi qui étaient aux
portes du royaume uni qui était sclérosé
par l'aristocratie des syndicats et
aussi il faut le dire l'économie dirigée
et ça qui est quand même assez étonnant
c'est qu'on a un jeremy corbyn qui
visiblement n'a pas eu vent de la chute
du mur de berlin et qui retourne un
programme assez socialiste il plaide
pour des tas de nationalisation en
de l'échec répété de ce genre de mesure
ça manque finalement que les idéaux
libéraux ne sont ne sont jamais acquis
nulle part et que et que les
ressentiments anti capitalistes n'ont
pas besoin d'un contexte économique
délétère pour ressurgir et se réaffirmer
face aux idéaux libéraux alors même
qu'on pensait à la fin de l'histoire
très vite le pour vous le break site
libéral ça dépend si on peut pas
répondre vu ou dans l'absolu ce juste un
commentaire sur le break site je pense
pas qu'il faille calquer
l'euroscepticisme français sur
l'euroscepticisme britannique ce sont
deux types de recettes estime qu'ils
sont complètement différents lors cette
liste le français on le sait il est
teinté de l'anticapitalisme recherche de
revanche à l'hostilité de principe
contre la mondialisation
là où les britanniques sont
historiquement et culturellement une
nation beaucoup plus commerçante
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour boris johnson
hilare affirmait il mendie des accords
de libre-échange auprès d'un tas de
puissance commerciale le canada les
etats-unis l'inde le l'australie donc il
ya une volonté libre échange est ce
aussi qui est affirmé et c'est en ce
sens que je me dirai quand même l'idée
qu'ils auraient un tournant antilibérale
cdd conservateurs puisque aujourd'hui le
l'euroscepticisme britannique est
beaucoup plus libre échangiste en tout
cas que nos artistes français nicolas
cora t'offre le libéralisme n'est pas
complètement d'accord avec mon voisin de
gauche mais presque c'est à dire que je
trouve que le l'exercice pour boris
johnson il est compliqué puisque il a
vendu entre guillemets au à la
population britannique le break site
et si c'est pour leur expliquer ensuite
que l'état ne rien faire parce que c'est
le marché qui dirige tout politiquement
il a un problème donc effectivement il
est en train biais ou pas de construire
un programme autour du retour en tout
cas de l'état c'est à dire qu'on a
quitté l'union européenne il faut bien
qu'on retrouve une place pour l'état et
donc il est en train d'inventer parce
qu'il a promises beaucoup boris johnson
il est en train d'improviser
le retour de l'état dans un pays qui
effectivement traditionnellement
économiquement en tout cas s'en est très
bien passé pendant des décennies donc il
est il est un peu renégats par rapport à
sa famille mais comme il est il a la
responsabilité ils portent la
responsabilité politique du départ de
l'union européenne
il doit reconstruire une place pour
l'état qui avait pratiquement disparu
entre la tradition très libéral
des britanniques et puis la politique
union de l'union européenne dont on sait
qu'elle fait peu de place aux états de
cas de moins en moins de place aux états
membres dans la gestion de leur économie
donc je crois qu'il est dans ce paradoxe
là moi je suis assez je suis assez
critique sur les gens qui considèrent
que boris johnson n'est pas un homme
politique de premier plan je pense qu'il
faut pas le sous-estimer
et en tout cas là il a trouvé une voie
de passage peut-être très étroite mais
qui peut lui permettre de parler de
parler au coeur des anglais à leur
portefeuille aussi on saura ça demain
soir en fait que le parti conservateur
est favori avant de vous donner la
parole du matin pour savoir si vous avez
envie d'aller vous installer au royaume
uni avec toutes ces annonces les
internautes qui nous suivent et qui
cependant sur twitter merci à eux
considèrent à 71% que non les élections
législatives ne marque pas la fin du
libéralisme économique autrement
j'espère me tromper mais je pense que
boris johnson va gagner les élections
demain en grande bretagne même si les
sondages des derniers sondages montrent
un certain resserre resserrement avec le
lay bas mais je pense qu'il va gagner et
ce qu'il faut noter c'est que les
circonscriptions qui sont qu'ils vont
basculer du côté du côté part du parti
conservateur du côté de johnson sont
essentiellement des sa construction
populaire qui était détenu jusqu'à
présent par le parti travailliste est là
qu est ce qui se passe il se passe que
l'électorat populaire qui a voté en
faveur du bric si tu pars pour toutes
les raisons que l'on sait sur le rejet
d'une certaine forme d'europe voilà donc
cet électorat sur l'immigration et
l'intégration cet électorat populaire
boris johnson pour le capter il a besoin
d'avoir à la fois un discours évidemment
propres exit mais aussi un discours
social c'est à dire qu' il ne peut pas
se contenter de l'es22 de leur proposer
le break site il faut aussi qu'ils leur
disent si si demain on garde le pouvoir
on va compenser le brésil par une forme
de d'intervention forte sociale et donc
du coup doudou les promesses mais de là
imaginer que boris johnson s'est s'est
converti au socialisme alors là on
ferait totalement fausse route epide
de l'autre côté il faut aussi dire que
jeremy corbyn sa campagne elle est quand
même plombée par des accusations hélas
justifié par rapport à ces dérives
antisémites
elle est plombée aussi par le fait que
le parti travailliste a cru faire de ces
élections un enjeu uniquement de
politique intérieure économique et
sociale sans en évacuant quasiment la
question du breakbeat et aujourd'hui
hélas il n'est pas suivi par il le paye
assez
je pense qu'il va le payer à ces
charmants rachel vinasse le mot de la
fin sur ce sujet je vois pas trop en
quoi justement cette campagne sonnerait
la liquidation du libéralisme économique
c'est à dire qu'on peut très bien
intégré certains éléments dits
socialistes à une icône une économie de
marché ou plus ou moins régulés donc je
ne vois pas de divorce majeur des
anglais avec avec cette économie là avec
l'économie de marché et on peut donc
intervenir
n'en déplaise à certains libéraux il
très libéraux on peut libérer pardon on
peut très bien intervenir tout en jouant
le jeu justement d'une voie là d'une
concurrence et le terme souverainisme
n'est pas antinomique avec sur lui de
libéralisme
ils peuvent se conjuguer l'exemple le
plus frappant c'est trump aux états unis
effectivement parce que l'est d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant de voir que dans un
certain nombre de parties de pays
européens
le populisme a été récupéré par des
parties extérieures à la droite
traditionnelle
je pense à l'italie où en france où les
républicains sont pas en très bon état
alors que ce etats-unis au royaume-uni
c'est les partis de droite classique qui
ont qui ont capté cet électeur tout
était fait nous allons avoir un petit
peu comment ça se recompose parce que
pour le moment c'est difficile mais j'ai
du mal un petit peu enterrés les partis
politiques les principaux je pense au ps
aux élèves je pense tout bas là il faut
faire attention mais en effet il ya des
partis qui ont très vite compris les
attentes
entouré d'une partie de l'électorat en
france pour le moment on est aux abois
il nous reste quelques minutes pour
parler de paris il y a
dans l'actualité